well we journalists love a good cliche
even if it's more than 40 years old so
we've dusted off the summer of
discontent as union leaders do battle
with employers over pay and jobs
we've had a week in which the rail
network virtually ground to halt on
tuesday ballot papers go out to more
than 115 000 postal workers over its pay
dispute with royal mail
joining me now is dave ward the leader
of the general uh the communication
workers union morning dave
what exactly
are you asking the royal mail and bt
bosses for
well it's about getting a pay rise that
recognises the impact of the cost of
living crisis
uh it's also about recognising the
efforts that work as all of our members
there's we've got disputes going on
right across the whole of the union at
the moment
um
that you know recognizes the efforts
that have kept these companies going i
mean the background to this as well as a
cost of living crisis
is the reality that bt posted profits of
1.3 billion last year royal mail 758
million
they paid shareholder dividends of 700
million and 400 million respectively and
i think what's making workers more and
more angry
is that the ceo of bt his pay has
actually gone up by 32 percent in the
last year in role now
the financial director uh apparently hit
all their targets and got 1.5 million
and the ceos just received a bonus of uh
140 000 pounds
so you know people are saying i think
enough's enough i want to come to all of
that in a moment but let's let's talk
about what it will mean for people who
would be watching this program
uh last week they couldn't get to work
because of the trains um that it looks
like they won't be able to fly on their
summer holidays so now actually if
somebody
sends them a parcel they won't be able
to get that either it's pretty miserable
isn't it well i think our job is to
represent workers um
and what i say to that to anybody
listening to this is that you know we
have a simple message which is
you know every work accounts or no work
accounts
and of course you know going on strike
is the last result you know we do that
when negotiations have felt
and we will be you know once we've done
our ballots we've got our bt ballots
that we announced the results of on
thursday as you said postal workers over
115 000 will be receiving their ballot
papers on tuesday um you know we'll be
making it public that we want
negotiations to resolve those disputes
so the objective is never a strike
um but this is this is a moment i think
and i hear the the message that you said
about the summer of discontent i mean
obviously the people who are trying to
create that image
uh is the is the government at the
moment
and you know i think people across the
uk
have sort of seen through some of these
tactics so what i would say to you is
this is if people look at the financial
crisis 2008 the pandemic
the cost of living crisis the climate
crisis the only certainty
in the uk at the moment if we don't make
a stand for all working people
is that the rich are going to get richer
and the powerful getting more powerful
and that's what we've got to address in
the uk including in how the economy
operates
just
well let's come to that in a second but
am i to understand that you really now
expect
that bt workers when balloted will
probably
reject any offer that's on the table and
that we're heading for industrial
election
with bt
well we didn't get a chance to reject
that well the union rejected their offer
our members
in bt across bt group never got a chance
because the same guy who increased his
earnings by 32 percent philip jansen the
ceo imposed
a pay deal of 1500 pound on the
workforce in role model they've imposed
a pay deal with 2
these things are unacceptable so snail
mail's off and email's going to be off
or you know whatever bt communications
uh represents um
the ceo of royal mail admits that his
workers deserve a pay right pay rise
he's put two percent uh on the table
five and a half percent uh on the table
as well uh is it reasonable to launch
industrial election
uh
against somebody who actually
sympathizes publicly with your members
well
it's reasonable to make a stand for
working people and our members will be
the judge of the actions of the ceo um i
have a different view of the way that
they are behaving at the moment
um i think if you look at you know it's
the same tactics it's about trying to
divide workers the the issues for us at
the moment in the uk and you know i
repeat this this is for all workers in
the uk
is that this can't carry on you cannot
continue to talk about leveling up to
talk about modernization when all of the
proposals that these companies come
forward with are actually leveling down
uh work the lives and the living
standards of working people it's not
acceptable you're in a slightly
different position to some of the others
uh
disputes teachers and so on because your
your your people work for private
company
isn't the problem here that uh you want
these pay demands to be met
but the royal mail ceo says he needs to
remain competitive in a tight market and
isn't it the case that if you win your
demands people are going to be happiest
won't be your members but the bosses at
dpd ups dhl fedex tnt and all the
competitors because royal mail prices
are going to go up they are going to
soak up the business and your members
will lose jobs
let me be absolutely clear this is not a
debate about affordability
both bt and royal mail group could
afford to pay workers more money they
say not um well they can this is simply
not true
i've just given you the numbers they
choose deliberately to put other
arguments on the table now this argument
about competition
uh and effectively that we should just
accept
the race to the bottom
um i think that's
a point we've reached a point now where
we have to challenge that argument and
that's why the tuc which hasn't been
picked up by the media is also running a
campaign at the moment which all unions
have signed up to and our union led this
campaign for a new deal for working
people and a new social settlement in
the uk and i think you're going to see
that support for that grow during the
course of the summer well it looks as
though actually there's a lot of this
going on across the union movement um
your colleague mr micklin she's become a
sort of television and social media star
and indeed do you have had some things
to say i think about
the labour party's support or lack
thereof for uh your dispute mr stama
zakir ordered his front benches to stay
away from the rmt's picket lines some
chose to ignore it but and i talked to
mr lammy this morning he wouldn't commit
himself on any of the disputes either
the rmt or indeed
yours how do you feel about the level of
support you're getting from the labour
party
well first of all
my answer to that is it's time for
unions to step up now community
organizations and run our own campaigns
and not rely
on any political party to solve our
problems and i think that's going to
increasingly be the reality of the
situation
when it comes to
you know the government i mean they're
picking a fight
they've chosen the side they're coming
out because like they do on everything
to try and divide working people i don't
think that's going to work i think
they've miscalculated i think labor have
miscalculated because i think they're
obsessed with you know reconnecting with
working people and
you know the reason that people moved
away from labour was over brexit i don't
think people are going to turn their
backs on working people
who are facing these challenges because
we're all
genuinely in that together and i think
labour have miscalculated um it's up to
keith starman what he does but what
we're going to do
is reach out to
working people across the uk
in communities coming together to really
bring about serious challenges you're
pretty hacked off with late party aren't
you
i i'm disappointed um but i don't let it
get us down you know i don't rely on
i've been around too long trevor to rely
on politicians to solve problems for you
this is a moment where trade unions
community organizations we all need to
step up and we need to shift the balance
of forces in the world of work in how
the economy operates and across society
dave ward thank you very much indeed for
your time thank you